sending you live you have 10 seconds
thank you
okay good evening everybody and welcome
to uh the virtual meeting of stratford
uneven district council's planning
committee this evening my name is
councillor peter richards and i will be
chairman for tonight's meeting a few
housekeeping issues before we go into
the
the main agenda please note the meeting
is being
live streamed and it is being recorded
for future publication on the council's
website
and youtube members you will have been
provided with the council's etiquette
for virtual meetings in advance of
tonight's meeting however just to
reiterate a few points for you
please make sure your device is either
charged or charging
please mute your microphones if you
haven't already done so and maintain
that muting until you are called
to speak of course remember to unmute
yourself when you do wish to speak
to register to speak if you could please
let me know in the meeting chat
i will then call on you at the
appropriate time
and if you could please turn off any
other devices or at least switch them to
silence so that we don't get interrupted
during the meeting that would be great
if for any reason you encounter it
problems causing you to either drop out
or completely
leave the meeting uh this evening please
make every effort to rejoin
if you can't uh we do have a number in
our
phone number in our meeting chat so you
go ahead and call that and you
someone will help you in rejoining again
if you're only able to rejoin at that
point you will have been deemed to have
left the meeting at the point in which
you lose connection
um and the the meeting will continue
provided we are still corrupt
uh i can also confirm now that checks
have been made in
uh in front of our legal officer to
ensure that members of the committee are
in attendance and all have confirmed in
the presence of the council's legal
officer that they can see
and hear all proceedings we do have a
series of officers online with us
tonight
starting from our legal department we
have mia mack
uh from democratic services uh we have
liv liz
jawaska and uh from planning we have
eddie wrench
and our planning manager this evening is
richard gardner
richard do you have a statement you want
to make
yes good evening everyone thank you mr
chairman uh just to confirm that my role
tonight is to provide impartial advice
and to assist members in their decision
taking thank you
thank you very much um for members of
the public who are speaking
um if i could ask those who have
registered to speak to please when they
come to speak to turn off
all streaming live streaming of this um
at this meeting
that might be in the background they do
those live streams do tend to be
slightly delayed
uh and can cause many problems for us uh
both
uh in the production of of the uh the
video feed uh but also in being able to
speak and hear from you so please make
sure those are
are either muted or off um you will be
given
a 30 second warning prior to the end of
your speech if you could please stay
online after that
for uh any questions that members may
have
and at that stage if you would hang up
and listen
to the the broadcast live through the
stream
that is the best way to do that
okay let's move into our main agenda so
first thing on the first item
is apologies do we have any apologies
please liz
yes thank you german we do we have
apologists from councillor adam and evan
thank you and any disclosures of
interests please remember
counselor dixon i believe you have one
indeed i do uh thank you mr chairman
um no personal interest but i have met
and spoken with the applicants
in respect of the application number
seven olive cottage and essentially
whilst i've met and spoken with the
applicants uh i will remove myself from
the committee and speak in support of
the application
thank you chad thank you very much i see
no others in the meeting chat so we will
move
uh on to the minutes can you please give
me a thumbs up
to confirm the minutes from our last
meetings on the 4th and 18th of november
i will sign those next time in the
office that is
everyone's thumb up fabulous good right
let's move to our first application
then um which is application number
1902826
that's land west of stratford lane south
of ulster road
north of eastern road in stratford upon
avon um
in line with our constitution we have
had
no registered speakers from the town
council or from
parish councils in which case we can
and indeed the um the update sheets
details a change in recommendation
which is to delegate the decision to
officers so i propose that we do move
to a delegation to officers could i have
a secondary
councilor mills has put his hand up i
see councillor kendall and councillor
jennings also typing second
i'm not going to ask you to speak to it
but thank you three of you uh let's have
a vote
um councillor richards four
thank you chairman councillor fleming
councillor flowing for councillor
kendall
councillor kendall four councillor crumb
it's a crop for councillor curtis
councilman curtis for councillor dixon
councillor dixon four councillor henshaw
seraphin
pence lehendra seraphine 4 councillor
jennings
councillor jennings ball councillor
mills
council mills 4 and councillor parry
councillor parry four thank you that's
unanimous chairman
thank you very much liz so committee
therefore resolves to delegate uh two
officers the decision
for application 1902 826 rem
let's move to our second one uh which is
in fact a combination of two so
um application numbers nineteen zero two
eight eight zero rem and
nineteen zero two eight two nine rem so
two reserve matters
for land west uh of stratford uh south
of ulster road north of eastern road in
stratfor and even
same site um the same things apply we
have had no
uh registered speakers for the town
council of parish council
and therefore uh i propose that we
uh move to delegate the decision to
officers could i have a sender i'm quite
happy for a thumbs up or someone in the
chat don't mind who's quicker
counselor jennings was first with a
thumbs up so councillor jennings seconds
that
i will vote first councillor richards
four
thank you chairman councillor fleming
cashier fleming four councillor kendall
candle 4 councillor crump
chancellor councillor curtis
councillor curtis or councillor dixon
councillor dixon for councillor henshaw
sarafin
and slahinger serving for councillor
jennings
councillor jennings for councillor mills
council mills for councillor parry
councillor parry four thank you that's
unanimous again chairman
thank you very much liz so uh in that
case uh committee has resolved
to delegate the decision to officers for
application nineteen zero two eight
eight zero rem and application nineteen
zero two
eight two nine rem we'll move on to our
next application and you're gonna hear
much of the same again i'm afraid so
application nineteen zero
two eight three one r e m that's land
west of stratford
uh land south of ulster road north of
eastham road in chicago um again we've
had
uh no registered speakers from either
paris town
parish or town councils so we can
delegate to
offices i propose we do that could i
please have danny
councillor kendall sorry has already
seconded uh thank you
uh cancer kendall i will vote first
councilor richards
four thank you chairman councillor
fleming
council fleming four thank you
councillor kendall
councillor kendall four councillor crump
caster crumpleball mr curtis
councillor kurtis for councillor dixon
councillor dixon for councillor hendrich
serafin
influential seraphine for councillor
jennings
council jennings ford councillor mills
council mills 4 and councillor parry
councillor parry 4 that's unanimous
chairman
fabulous thank you so much um in that
case committee resolves to delegate
to officers decision for application
number 1902831rem
fabulous right now to a a slightly more
detailed application which is
application number twenty zero one zero
four eight
f u l that is olive cottage in
hockley heath do we have our speakers in
i've just been notified we do
thank you very much so eddie wrench is
our presenting officer
eddie whenever you are ready it is over
to you
thank you chair i'll just get the
presentation ready
okay we should be showing now
um yes that's good good thank you sorry
just confirming
uh the application uh is for the
dismantling and reconstruction of gate
pillars
and replacement of gate installation of
a greenhouse and garage
olive cottage which is on the stratford
road just north of the m40 as shown here
by the black dot
[Music]
the application dwelling is a grade two
listed cottage
and with extensive garden land as shown
here by the
red line outline
the application site
can be seen here so the stratford road
runs to the east of the site
with the grated listed cottage in the
center their proposal
is to create a new vehicular access
into the garden land uh with a new
garage in the northern portion of the
site
uh as well as that there would be a new
uh greenhouse which would be located
directly to the rear of the house in the
west
uh as part of the works the existing
gate
uh pedestrian gate into the house would
be widened with new
pillars to create that new vehicular
access
uh here are the proposed and existing
elevations from the highway so the
existing is the
uh it's the current uh pedestrian access
into the site and this would be widened
with new gates
and pillars
these are the proposed elevations for
the
proposed garage which would be timber
clad
this is um the suppliers details in
terms of the greenhouse
so it would be approximately three
meters by six meters
with particular details as shown here
sorry these are some photos from the
rear garden
of the property the
bottom left-hand photo is the
approximate location where the new
garage would go
with the proposed greenhouse would be
directly to the rear of the house which
can be seen on the bottom right
and top right of the photo here
and finally here's a google image from
the
highway looking towards olive cottage
um the proposed access into the site
would utilize this
already drop curb into the site
um and then obviously the widening with
the new gates would be into this
location
uh currently compare vehicular traffic
to the
to the site utilizes the grass verge
and the dropped curb area
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
planning permission for the reasons
on page 60 of the agenda
updates include a new response from
councillor dixon and detailing it with
uh an officer's response to some of the
points raised
um so yeah german
over to you thank you
eddie thank you very much um we will go
straight to our speakers so we have no
passion town councillors
uh registered speaker no objectives so
our first speaker is
our applicant mrs brandt uh mrs brandt
are you there welcome can you hear us
you may need to press star six to unmute
your microphone
sorry chair there is um a presentation
which he's presented which i'll show as
well which is a recorded voice
so hello there i can't i can't hear you
but oh yes i have given a presentation
yeah i think she's uh mrs brandt is
going to ask answer any questions after
the presentation so i'll just get that
ready if that's okay
understood go ahead
and if you let us know when it's playing
that would be great yeah sorry
started already
sorry
right
okay should be playing now
we can see but we can't hear oh you
can't hear that
no have we sampled this playing of a
of sound or before uh it's playing on my
computer so i don't know why it's
not playing on yours let me try again
is this possible
now we we can't actually hear anything
at the moment i think that the trouble
is that what we're trying to do now is
is um your speakers will have prevented
uh prevented its own microphone from
picking up what the speakers are sending
um some of the it works that way to turn
off my speaker is it is that
no i think i i just don't i'm not clear
that it's going to work if i'm honest
um mrs brandt do you have the scripts
that you uh that you used to read
when you recorded this
mrs brown you may need to press star and
six to unmute yourself again so that we
can hear you
hi
hello mrs brown can you hear okay i can
yes
fabulous um do you still have the
scripts that you used to read
so i'll tell you what if we start at um
at uh
the first page of your presentation and
if you want to start speaking and
when you want to change to your next
slide if you just say next slide
eddie will move it on to on to the next
slide and then if you carry on speaking
and we'll be able to follow from here
okay it might just take a bit longer
than three minutes because i
haven't factored in next slide but yeah
okay
we we can give you some brace for a few
seconds that's fine okay whenever you're
ready to go we're on the first slide now
so as soon as you're ready to go please
go ahead
okay these items would normally be
clustered for
permitted development but are restricted
on listed properties so a
conservationist can assess what if any
harm the proposals would have
she deems all three acceptable the
plumber states the garage and driveway
significantly harm the character of the
area
we disagree this is far more harmful and
surely
safety overrides everything next slide
the plan estates are a double garage
to provide safer parking and storage
facilities for our cars possessions and
tools to maintain the cottage and garden
is inappropriate due to the effect on
openness of the greenbelt
as you can see the garage would not be
visible from the road due to the
evergreen trees and shrubs
next slide the planning inspectorate
ruled on an appeal case involving a
similar double garage on garden land in
greenbelt
and found in favour of the home owner
stating a double garage is of modest
scale
therefore the effect on openness is
minimal and development would not be
inappropriate and would not complete
with national guidance
next slide the planner states the garage
must be within five metres of the
cottage
development management considerations
state the word should
not must which is presumably how this
garage was approved even though it is 33
meters away from its listed property
ours would only be 22. this property is
three doors away from our cottage why
are our smaller proposals unsuitable
next slide this garage is half a mile
from our cottage and was approved in may
this site already included a previously
approved double garage
in the past year five double garages
have been approved under pd and full
plans
all are located in the same green belt
and special landscape area
the high court backed the planning
inspector who took into account the
local authority's approach to similar
proposals in the locality stating
consistency is required as a broad
principle of good administration and
derives from general principles of
fairness in the treatment of citizens
the report makes no reference sorry next
slide the report makes no reference
to core strategy hc which states
integrating new developments into
historic assets will be encouraged to
secure their viability
it is incomprehensible that those
charged with protecting the cottage
think it acceptable to store garden
tools bikes and ladders within it
next slide the building for life12
initiative endorsed by stratford states
good design includes
external secure storage for garden
equipment and cycles within garages or
traditional
if you aren't persuaded by these facts
we believe we have demonstrated a number
of unique and very special circumstances
including
next slide removing cars from parking on
the highway is a safer option for all
road users and would improve the area in
general
including a garage to store cars limits
visual harm to the cottage and addresses
security concerns given the garden is
unfenced
a fully glazed greenhouse has no impact
whatsoever on openness encourages an
active lifestyle
the planner states the garden is
undeveloped but that is not strictly
true
an outbuilding previously occupied the
site these proposals simply reinstate
that building as a site without storage
is totally impractical for any owner
if you aren't decided but next slide by
these points are raised then i
respectfully request you defer and visit
to see for yourself how dangerous
current parking arrangements are
thank you
mrs brandt thank you very much for that
um marginally over 30 minutes but i
think we'll give you that grace given
uh the technical issues that we were
having and the need to
uh instruct us to change slides uh if
you could just hang on the line for
one moment when i see if our members
have any questions for you
uh councillor parry certainly does so
council parry over to you
thank you chairman and and good evening
um you made reference to
a former outbuilding um
can you advise when this was removed or
demolished
um and what's the history behind that
please all i know
because it was demolished by the
previous owner that were an italian
family
and they demolished it for safety
reasons
um i believe it was sort of quite a
dilapidated l-shaped building
and if you look in the design and access
statement you can actually see it on the
title deeds
and and could you just explain to me
where whereabouts its location was in
relation to where
your proposals for a garage and a
greenhouse
yeah um can you could you see you can't
bring the picture up because i can't see
can i
if you if you look on the i don't know
if he can show you the plan
yeah we've got the plan up front okay
yeah we have a bird's eye view of your
property at the moment
okay so um and is that the plan where it
showed where our garage is going to be
correct yes so if you look to the
left of that directly to the left
it was um it's well it's in that same
parcel of land basically it's an open
parcel of land
and there's just a sort of a weeping
willow tree now that
i don't if you can bring up the actual
um google map
but there's a weeping willow tree and
this l-shaped building was completely
the other side of the weeping willow
so it's just sort of moved from one side
of the
it's it i don't know if you can see that
weeping willow
we we can yeah we have people as well so
that there are indentations
to the left of the weeping willow that
show where the footings of this building
the indentations are still there okay
thank you
interesting thank you very much um
sorry if you look on the title dude
you'll see each show
okay um we sadly we don't have access to
uh title deeds but
um no that they're in my they're in my
design and access statement
okay um councilor jennings has a
question for you mrs brent council
journey
good evening um hello there obviously
you've done
a lot a lot of homework on what's been
uh
being done in other people's gardens
within your vicinity
um do you know if any of those are also
grade two listed
yes the one that i showed you the
picture of with the large one that's got
the room on top that's great too
listings
i think it's called nuthurst i believe
okay thank you very much thank you very
much
um members are there any further
questions i'll give you a couple of
seconds if you wanted to ask another
question
lots of shaking heads no okay uh mrs
brandt thank you very much for joining
us
this evening uh you will be best placed
to continue watching on the
live stream uh if that's okay uh so if
you could hang up your phone and
continue to watch
that's great but thank you again for
your contribution thanks very much
marvelous thank you and councillor dixon
is our next speaker
councillor dixon welcome hello good
evening you have five minutes with 30
second warning whenever you're ready
please go ahead thank you chairman
members
prior to this meeting you have read the
office's report and the update sheet the
officer concludes that the gate pillars
and the gate
are acceptable but the greenhouse and
the garage have a detrimental impact
upon the openness of the green belt
because they are new buildings within
the green belt
and not being within five meters of a
listed building
they cannot be considered as extensions
i had requested a site visit to enable
everyone to fully appreciate the
topography and the layout of the garden
which is enclosed by mature trees but
otherwise
is mostly known grass with the exception
of the southernmost part
where trees dominate and where it was
initially indicated that the garage was
situated i.e
in undeveloped part of the garden
possibly as described in the offices
report second paragraph page 56
the position of the garage its size and
its design
were amendments received subsequent to
the first approach by mrs brandt
the size and the position of the
greenhouse has remained constant
throughout
as has the material proposed for the
drive i.e
gravel because the officer has concluded
that the proposed
garage and greenhouse being new
buildings have a detrimental impact
and harm the openness of the green belt
the application should be refused
in the absence of very special
circumstances
now the purpose of the green belt is to
avoid urban sprawl
and although the report indicates at the
top of page 57
that the property lies within the
village any of you who may have driven
past to better appreciate the access
difficulties
would i'm sure conclude that there is no
urban sprawl
anywhere near this isolated or remote
cottage
hence given the enclosed nature of the
site i do not consider
there to be any harm to the openness of
the greenbelt
and the greenbelt is not put at risk if
you agree with my assessment
and reject the assessment of the officer
you can do this
but if you wish to for a reason think
of this why do listed buildings have
their pd rights
removed my answer to this is very simple
to protect the setting of the listed
building and for
no other reason the conservation officer
has concluded
after much negotiation and amendments to
the application
that these proposals do not harm the
listed building
so members please use your discretion to
reach a different conclusion to the
officer
and support this request thus providing
mrs brandt and
her family the usual elk buildings
associated
with many other family properties in the
green belt
a garage and a greenhouse if you think
that these
are too large and may cause harm
then please ask the planning officers
what buildings
can be erected in the cartilage
of this listed building in the green
belt
if the answer is none then please
consider
how mrs brandt and her family or any
other future owner
can realistically use their property
and store bicycles lawn mowers and other
paraphernalia the garage the car
obviously is
extra to the garage paraphernalia thank
you chairman thank you members
pastor dixon thank you very much members
do we have any questions for our ward
member
any couple of seconds if you want to
type into our meeting chat
i don't see much action
nope okay so council dixon thank you
very much
we will move to clarification from
offices
um eddie i do have a couple of questions
if i may
uh to start us off um first
question have you put any thought or was
there any thoughts to this being
defined as limited infill between two
buildings in the green belt
not to my knowledge it has it's not uh
it's not uh raised within the um
uh officers report i don't know if it
would
count as that anyway i
i mean my immediate reaction my
immediate thought is oh clearly there
are buildings
between buildings to the north of
um olive cottage and the proposal is to
situate
a building between those two um
i wonder whether that would be an
applicable um
allowable building within the green belt
because it
it could be considered limited info if
you don't have the answers to that now
that's fine i shall ask our other
members to have
their questions i do have a second one
but i'll do i'll leave that towards the
end
yeah should i move on to our other
members and you can come back to mine
yeah if i'll have a look in the interim
but if you've got any questions yeah
yeah
please um councillor jennings has a
question for you
thank you sir i'm just uh wanting to ask
you
i know with grade 2 you can't put
anything in your garden
couldn't can you put up a garden shed
and they would require planning
permission in the same way
even if it was a small i don't know five
foot by two foot one
in terms of yeah even for that size
because it's listed and
any out building requires planning
permission so even if it's a small one
um i think the the difference is with
these that if it was
within five meters of the property it
could be considered an extension to the
property
so if it was a small greenhouse or or a
small um
uh shed within it if it was within five
meters then it could be considered an
extension
and maybe considered appropriate in
those circumstances
but any bill out building would require
planning permission
okay thank you okay councillor mills has
a question for you councillor mills
yeah thanks mr chairman um yeah eddie um
um
i i have mean to see this uh because of
the code of restrictions but
um eddie can this be seen um
from anywhere i mean are they are they
completely hidden from
from view from the road or from
neighbors
uh it is very verdant the site so there
is a lot of
boundary trees and vegetation so if
there is any views they'll be extremely
uh limited i would say okay
thanks okay
councillor parry has a question as well
please counselor parry
thank you chair i was just interested on
the situation with regarding the former
out building and the site it was located
on
and therefore if there was a um a
previous building
on this particular site which obviously
is
included in the um land
registry and deeds then
does the does the garage not at least
count as a replacement
dwelling and therefore could be
permitted
um and that the openness of the green
belt does not apply because there was
previously a building
an outbuilding there or is that because
the policy on greenbelt has changed
obviously since the removal of that
previous outbuilding
uh as soon as the building's demolished
it can't be
considered against greenbelt or anything
like that so
i don't know the details but looking
from the aerial view and the photos i
would imagine it's been a considerable
time since it's been demolished
and so in terms of
it couldn't be considered against any
sort of uh volume calculations or green
belt assessments
okay thank you okay councillor curtis
has a question for you as well council
curtis
yes thank you chair um i mean i've i've
i know this house
fairly well i've driven past it many
many times and
certainly the the garden itself is fully
screened
from the road um and i do have sympathy
um that you know it's a busy fast
road at that point and you know
looking at that uh the existing parking
area i think that is
pretty dangerous and eddie i just wanted
to sort of
a pedantic point if i may and i'm sorry
to do this but
the garden shed i mean often people put
a garden shed
as i have in the town at the bottom of
my garden
so i mean just to be clear
even a small garden shed put i don't
know behind the
weeping willow tree so it was distant
from
the house which would you know probably
be a good place to put one
that would need planning permission
and would probably and would presumably
get the same response from officers
that it should be refused in terms of
the green bout assessment it's quite
black and white in terms of how things
are assessed so yeah it is very much
that
unless it's within five meters of the
house um
unless there's very special
circumstances then it would be
inappropriate development
yeah that's great thanks for that
clarification thank you
thank you uh eddie back to my question
you haven't had much opportunity there
to look at it have you well
yeah it's always difficult i'm happy to
answer this one chair
if yeah if you're if you're comfortable
i don't mind whether it's you already
okay um limited infilling is covered
under policy cs10
c for those of you who've got your core
strategies open
um and it's listed there as one of
the forms of development in the green
belt that are
not inappropriate in principle so in
effect they are appropriate
um c says
that it is acceptable to have the
limited infilling or the partial or
complete redevelopment
of a previously developed brownfield
site
whether redundant or in continuing use
and this is the important bit subject to
it not having a materially greater
impact on the openness of the green belt
and the purpose of including land within
it than the existing development
so you would get to the same conclusion
that officers have already got to
on that point because we would say that
it has a materially greater impact
these buildings um than what stands
there today
so it we we wouldn't go but i'm sorry
to talk over you yeah richard the
so is it either limited infilling
or the partial or complete redevelopment
of a previously developed site
i understand comma is i haven't got it
in front of me unfortunately but the
comma is there and that comma
differentiate limited infilling or
the partial or complete redevelopment
oversight and i know that's how we've
applied it within other areas as well
oh i see to my way of thinking and
i'm sort of slowly moving into a debate
here but i want to understand officer's
thoughts on this
this could be classed as limited infill
if one were to go along the lines of
um the uh partial complete redevelopment
of a previous development site well we
know
uh from the design and access statement
where we can see that there is
um uh of the d the title deeds show
there being a
a uh some form of development in that
area
it's clearly a previously developed site
so it's
it's either a limited infill or it's a
previously developed site either way
those two are applicable those two that
that part of cs10
bullet point c is applicable i i want to
understand
if what your rebuttal is to that being
applicable essentially so why
you don't think that is the case i don't
think i i'd rebut you at all
on the point about it being developed
obviously
even without the building not being
there anymore it it's currently in
a developed use ie a dwelling with its
curtain so that's a developed use anyway
um so i wouldn't uh question that uh i
think i just want time to re-read that
to pick up on your point about where the
comma sits because that's important
on how you read it as to whether the
final part of the paragraph applies to
the limited infilling
or just the part after all so i if you
could just bear with me
uh and eddie you may want to have a look
at that as well yeah
give the right advice okay um i do have
more questions and i know counselor
parry has as well
should we should we let you uh richard
do you want to have a look at what we've
just talked about
and eddie if you can respond to the
questions and then we can we can then
pick up with richard if that's okay okay
now cancer paris indicated this week so
i'll let council apparently ask a
question first and i'll follow up with
mine
so cancer parry thank you chair i just
um was interested in the officer's view
whether
um road safety in terms of the parking
of the cars on the busy road counted as
special had had any weight um
in terms of counting towards special
circumstances because
of the whole safety issue
it's a difficult one because the
officers aren't holding their
objection to the access or the change to
gates
and uh the works in terms of a drive
could be undertaken and under permitted
development so the actual bit that can
be commit development is the
formation of hard standing for a drive
so in in that sense they could take
vehicles off the road into the site
it's mainly the objection to the uh
garage
and the uh greenhouse in terms of of the
impact really so
so yeah it's a difficult one in term
obviously uh the garage store would um
mean that cars wouldn't be situated in
the open so there would be some
improvement in openness from
hiding them away to an extent as well
but in terms of purely road safety i
think it was felt that
you know there is ways um
that could be done without those
buildings that would be acceptable to
officers
okay thanks thank you early um
i think i'm trying to agree with you
that um so
uh back to my questions um
mrs brandt referred to specific policy
within our own core strategy
uh about allowing uh dwellings to have
outside stores ostensibly for bikes and
tools and other bits and pieces um
i'm trying to get my head around how
that would how we can apply that or how
one would apply that
to this uh this property in this
application it seems to me looking at
the google maps and the
the pictures that we've seen that there
are no external stores
um what uh what thought process have you
given
to this garage also being part of the
store for
the bikes and the tools and and such
like
it's it's a difficult one in terms of
that because there are certain things
you know if there was i think it was
talking before if there was a small shed
that was close to the house for for
storage of bikes and
garden paraphernalia that would more
than likely be acceptable to officers so
that
it is felt that there is options
available
um which could fulfill that that need
that don't go to the extent of the
garage
that's being proposed here
okay answer your question uh you kind of
yeah um so the the final bit that i
wanted to talk about was the
um the fact that we've been uh told and
indeed in the design access theme and
there's reference to
the title deed that shows an l-shaped
building to
the uh west of the weeping willow
i think it's west i'm hoping i'm getting
my geography right
um it's clearly not there now
is there any uh
is there any way or how are we able to
consider that knowing that there has
been buildings there in the past
i think and i think also parry might
have asked this question slightly before
but
i just wanted you to reiterate for me so
i'm clear in my head
in terms of green belt policy um it is
very much about the extent
of the existing volume as it is today so
as soon as something's been demolished
and
and there's um you know basically being
uh
absorbed by the landscape so it's almost
um
it's not clear now that there was a
building there then
it's not really in purely green belt
terms then it wouldn't be a
consideration at that stage obviously if
it was still
still there and they were proposing to
demolish it and
have this as an alternative it would it
would be a consideration at that point
but because of
it's being demolished in the time that's
passed then yeah it doesn't become a
consideration in terms of that volume
calculation anymore
unless it it falls under bullet point c
as either limited infill or a
full or partial redevelopment of a
previously developed site so clearly
that had previous development on it
yeah i mean in terms of gardens in terms
of the um
previously developed land in terms of
the mppf i think uh garden land is that
i can't remember if it's in villages or
um i'd have to get it
i was gonna segue into mr gardner there
who has has taken a lot of time and and
patience to work it out so uh richard do
you want to give us your
your thoughts on that mata please yes of
course
um what i've done is i've gone to the
mppf
paragraph 145 which is where we get cs10
from so it's the national policy on it
and it's worded slightly differently or
set out differently
in paragraph 145g of the mppf
and and the way it's worded to me
confirms that the
the point about not having a greater
impact on the openness of the green belt
refers both
to the redevelopment part of it and the
limited infilling part of it
because it's set out in a list following
an initial introduction of it's either
limited infilling
or complete redevelopment which would
and then there's a colon and then
there's a list
and one of those things on the list is
not having a greater impact on the
openness
so with that in mind that to my mind
clears up the ambiguity
that could exist from c of our own
policy um
even without reading the mppf i would
have still said that the
openness point the materially greater
impact point refers to limited infilling
as well
so you can do limited infilling but it
can't be materially greater
okay i think we could probably go
backwards and forwards on this because
it depends on the site i suppose doesn't
it really um
okay that's helpful thank you uh members
do you have any more questions for
officers before we move into the debates
seeing some shaken heads nothing no okay
who would like to start the debate
please someone jump in counselor perry i
can usually rely on you okay
jennings is in good manner councillor
jennings please
go ahead and i've driven past
this uh this site on many of the
occasion
and i've had i've had the unfortunate
experience of actually having watching
someone reverse in there
uh once i've screeched to a halton and
winched um
it's they definitely need to get the
cards off
off the road there i mean i know they're
brightly colored as well
i've noticed that um a long time ago and
it's
it's a bit of a certainly a road hazard
um
i know that they can they can build
a driveway in there and get the cars off
the road
um yeah
for safety sake i can understand the
need for a garage
whether there's a need or i don't think
there are any
i don't think there's a rule that says
you have to have a garage
um
my gut says i'm desperately looking for
a way to
to grant this but at the moment i'm
still struggling and i'm sort of
looking through my notes so i'll let
someone else speak
okay thank you very much councillor
parry
thank you thank you chairman one second
i'm coming from where matt's actually um
councillor jennings is coming
i do feel that this is limited
infill um
but my concern is about trying to
um come up with sufficient special
circumstances as well because the
there aren't any but having said that
when i read the
nppf um and it's
0.145 g
it does say it's worded in exactly the
same way without the commas etc
and it does say limited infilling
and you know we're not talking about
putting a house
in someone's back garden um
we also there's clearly been a president
on um neighboring properties where
they've also
put a garage in i've got i think i think
my
i've got less problem actually with
putting the garage in
i've got more problem with the
greenhouse because i think that is
at least the proposed garage is on the
site
of um the previous outbuilding
whereas the greenhouse is elsewhere um
i'm interested to hear what other people
say but
uh like matt jennings i i would like to
see a little bit of
see if we can find a way um
to get to to for sufficient
planning material reasons to grant this
but i'm i'm just struggling to find them
at the moment
councilman thank you councillor parry uh
councilman mills has has got a comment
to make chancellor mills
yes thanks mr chairman um
to me this is doesn't seem to be
interfering with anybody
but i i do go along with what ann was
saying about the size of the
the greenhouse um special circumstances
i i would think
safety is a special circumstance where
they can
store things away and lock them away
lock their cars away get them off the
road
um i'm all for granting this but
you know we've got to give some good
reasons so i'll um
i'll think on that one mr chairman at
the moment i'm i'm going for grant on
this at the moment
thank you but i'll wait to see what
everybody else has to say thank you
thank you very much council mills you
are quite right we do need to have uh
good solid reasons for going against our
officers um
on this uh this application so we need
to make sure that's sound
um i have a view but i'm going to ask
councillor curtis to come in before i
give
my two pennies worth councillor curtis
thank you chair
um yes i mean just
agreeing with with pretty much everyone
really um
the answer parry and uh apart from with
with councillor paraguay um
in some respects i i think the green
house
would actually enhance the the property
the design is actually something
very much that you might have found in a
property of that that sort of period
um obviously yes we i agree um we
we need to find reasons i think the and
again
like council jennings i've driven past
here a lot of times as i said earlier
i think road safety is a genuine
issue at this property so
perhaps that provides the way and as it
has been mentioned the um
the infill thank you chad
you're muted peter you're muted uh
i do apologize i gave a lovely speech
just then it was fabulous
it was jen's fortunately i can't
remember what i said
um what i said was i i see two more
members have
indicated their wish to speak before i
give my thoughts i shall ask counselor
kendall to come in first
thanks chair right uh
okay i i like everybody else i would
love to grant this
uh i'm looking at it it seems fine
um but i'm gonna be the unpopular one
because i'm going to say that we're all
sitting here saying i would love to
grant this but i can't come up with a
planning reason
i'm going to be the unpopular one and
say if that's the case
we have to follow the rules we have to
go with our own policies we have to go
with the
planning officer i heard people talk
about safety and the road safety
we've heard already that the uh new
gates
could be put gate pillars could be put
in uh anyway that would be fine
as part of a different application and
that would solve the road safety i think
but i'm afraid i'm sorry i i can't see
a reason to grant at this point because
we
sorry let me rephrase that i'm
struggling to find material grounds to
back up that particular proposal so i
can't go with that so at this point
i'm forced to go along with the officers
i'm not making a formal proposal yet but
i'd like to hear what other people think
on that
thank you councillor kendall uh
councillor hunter seraphin
ah thank you chair um i don't see any
problem with this garage building
spoiling the openness at all uh
people should have a safe place to put
their items
even the cars and as for the greenhouse
aren't we for green policies and growing
things
you know that's important today we
should be growing more things
that would really enhance the place if
they're growing
whether it's flowers or vegetables
anyway
i shall uh be in favor of granted this
thank you cassandra sarafin thank you
very much
um council fleming has indicated
uh well he said something in our chat um
do you want to speak to what you said or
are you happy for me to chuck my
my thoughts in at this stage
i can't say we need to proceed okay
cool thank you um i've taken quite a lot
of notes here
so look i think it's fair to say that
the majority of members on the committee
um would like to find reason to grant
the trouble is we we are bound by um
both the mppf and our own core strategy
and they are quite explicit
um where i
and this is my view and i think it's
shared by most of you
um but we will find out shortly uh where
i'm at is that um
limited infilling is permitted is one of
the permitted um
uh forms of development within the green
belt so my way of thinking this could be
defined could and should be defined as a
limited infill
plot that would allow for such a
development
we also have um and specific to this
site
one could describe it especially
circumstances the fact that
there is evidence of through title deeds
that that piece of land or marginally to
one side of it has been developed before
so if it's not classed as infill which i
think it should be or could be
we have a special circumstance in that
it has been developed before
um quite simply the the applicants are
looking to uh
to place or to replace what has
previously been demolished
um now
i think that on its own is probably a
little weak
where that is backed up is the need for
a secure place to store things like
bicycles and tools and other bits and
pieces which evidently is lacking
on this site i would add that to
a reason why we could grant permission
for um the garage
where i'm struggling and councillor
paris already made this point
is the greenhouse it is it is i think i
read
40 square meters
20 square meters forgive me the garage
is 40.
20 square meters for the greenhouse
approximately 60 cubic meters
that's not insubstantial in itself
but it is glass could a see-through
building have a material
impact on the openness of the green belt
it's a tough it's tough to argue i guess
either side
uh clearly it's built form and and by
virtue of that then
yes it probably would so i'm struggling
the issue i'm having or the
the area i'm struggling with is is the
um is the
the greenhouse i think i think we could
safely argue
uh uncomfortably argue policy to support
the garage but the greenhouse i'm
struggling with
unless anyone has any um suggestion
as to why we could or how we could
uh find policy to support the greenhouse
i'm
i'm struggling to find an uh anything to
put forward a proposal to grant
council jennings has indicated this wish
to speak at this point i'm assuming on
what i've just said so council jennings
you want to come in
yeah and i tend to agree though and if
we can get away
if we can say if we use the infill
argument
um for the garage sort of i
i'd be i'd be really happy to to
to propose granting but it's the
greenhouse which is the problem
um and i'm struggling i know that
it's perhaps being suggested a climate
emergency for a gr
for a greenhouse i think we're really
stretching it
um but because we've got to judge this
on the whole application we can't turn
around and say
well we can grant it as long as you
don't put the greenhouse in there
it doesn't work like that they'd have to
put in a separate application
minus the greenhouse and the chances are
we'd all turn around and go yep it's not
a problem
but at the end of the day because
there's a greenhouse element in here as
well
i'm going to i want to grant it but i
won't be able to
okay thank you um
yeah i i mean i completely agree um do
any other members have anything they
want to say
at this stage um i am going to speak to
our officers in just a moment about
reasons to refuse or
reasons for refusal sorry
um okay thank you councillor parry
uh for members of the public counselor
parry has has made a proposal
um and it's been seconded by councillor
kendall
council parry before before we do refuse
i'm going to ask you to um uh
to provide your uh your proposal
verbally um
but i just want to be clear um are you
my suggestion to you oh sorry
i don't want to be rude i'm trying not
to be i'm trying to be as bright as
possible my my
my suggestion would be that if we are
going to
refuse that we refuse on the grounds of
the greenhouse
being the problem yeah you're not in
good i think you're going along those
same lines
um and that actually the committee does
not have a particular issue with
the garage by virtue of the fact that
it's in phil and so on and so forth
do you want to i've kind of done it do
you want to no
i mean i think it's really important um
for the history of these the the history
of this site in terms of planning
applications
um that we highlight that um
that we have no problem um we would
the the development of the garage there
um fulfills the infill policy
as i said when i opened up my biggest
problem was the greenhouse
because of where it was and also it's
its actual size
and we don't and and it's the greenhouse
that actually goes against policy
i don't have a problem with the garage
and i think it's unfortunate
that it's it's all lumped in together so
my view would be but i think it's really
important
that the the reasons for refusal
also indicate that we would support
the development of the garage on the
proposed site because
it's infill but also because of the it's
a it's on a previous site of
of an outbuilding but because of the
scale
um and size of the greenhouse it does
and its distance from the main dwelling
it does have an impact on the openness
of the green belt
fabulous i like that um eddie
and richard are you happy with what
you've just
heard and uh you're happy to to form the
exact wording of the
reason for refusal on the lines of what
you've just heard
eddie do you want to speak first yes is
the answer i'm looking for
yes sorry i'm just looking at the the
reasons for refusal as
as set um so
obviously reason for refusal
to is is you wouldn't want that one
yeah that's correct and i think we can
just change the the first one local
planners already considered
that the and we can change that to the
greenhouse would not
fall within any exceptions the new
buildings in the green belt
okay i think that to be honest that
probably is all we need to do when in
terms of changes
do you counselor paris do you agree i'll
see you nodding fantastic
uh richard are you you're comfortable
with that um
if i can just check then because
effectively we're
you're not prejudging any future
application but you you're you're going
some way to that with regards to the
garage
just to understand it sounds like
the garage is acceptable because it's
considered to be limited infill
not because it's inappropriate but
there's very special circumstances it's
the former one by the sounds of it
yeah that's right now
yes do we need to refer to that within
the reason
for refusal or can we specifically refer
to i think we should specifically be
referring to the greenhouse being what's
what's put us off um no you don't need
to refer to it in the reasons for
refusal because it's a reason for not
refusing so it shouldn't be in there at
all
i think the fact that the minutes of
this meeting will record
uh what members felt on that will will
be enough for anyone in the future to
understand how the decision was made
good good that's that's what's important
for me okay good i think we're i think
we're settled and happy
um council kendall has seconded do you
want to formally second that verbally
please yes i do have to settle
cracking thank you very much let's move
to a vote i'll go first councillor
richards
four thank you chairman councillor
fleming
cancer flaring for councillor kendall
councillor kendall four councillor crump
cancer cronk four that's the curtis
councillor curtis abstain i really can't
find the right way through this i'm
afraid
thank you council um councillor henshaw
seraphin
um oliver stein as well yes
thank you thank you councillor jennings
councillor jennings ball councillor
mills
council mills 4 and councillor parry
councillor parry four thank you that's
seven four chairman and two abstentions
fabulous thank you liz therefore uh
committee resolves to refuse
planning application twenty zero one
zero four eight full
for the reasons we have just laid out
there being no urgent business i can now
prepare the meeting closed thank you all
very much for your contributions tonight
thank you to our officers all
planners legal and committee services
your support is hugely appreciated
thank you thanks very much